vamos a suponer que yo soy un
prestamista y que a ti te urge que te
preste un peso por algún motivo no sé
con ese peso vas a poder alimentar a tus
hijos
o empezar un nuevo negocio o comprar un
traje nuevo o comprar una casa en
cuernavaca qué sé yo y tú vienes y me
dices sal necesito un peso y después de
un año yo te lo voy a pagar y otra vez y
claro está bien te lo voy a prestar pero
con una condición por este peso que yo
te voy a prestar te voy a cobrar una
tasa del 100 por ciento de interés anual
así que vamos a escribirlo si tú me
tomas el préstamo de un peso al cien por
ciento de interés anual entonces al cabo
de un año tú me vas tener que regresar
mi peso el peso que te preste más del
100 por ciento de ese peso como paga del
préstamo que te hice porque te lo cubre
al 100 por ciento de interés anual
entonces al peso inicial al peso que te
estoy prestando se le conoce en términos
de economía como capital y bueno a este
capital inicial después de un año tú me
lo vas a tener que regresar completo y
además me vas a tener que regresar un
peso multiplicado por el 100%
cien por ciento de la tasa de interés
anual que te estoy cobrando bueno y esto
que va a ser igual un peso del capital
inicial que te estoy prestando más un
peso de los intereses que te estoy
cobrando me va a dar un total de dos
pesos después de un año tú me vas a
tener que pagar dos pesos de hecho está
módica tasa de interés no es tan baja es
de hecho de las más altas si nosotros la
comparamos con la tasa de interés que te
da un banco te dan casi siempre una tasa
de interés del 2.5 al 3% anual
y bueno si comparamos las dos tasas de
interés te vas a dar cuenta que la mía
es extremadamente alta pero como te urge
el dinero me vas a decir bueno sal si
acepto tu préstamo pero seguramente vas
a estar pensando en pagarlo lo más
rápido posible entonces seguramente vas
a decir oye sal y qué pasa si yo me
apuro le echó ganas y te lo pago en 6
meses bueno si te lo pago en 6 meses
entonces te voy a cobrar una tasa de
interés del 50 por ciento ya me estoy
bajando a la mitad entonces estos dos
pesos sería si tú las pagarás en un año
qué pasa si lo paras antes si lo logras
pagar en seis meses
entonces lo que tendrás que pagarme es
un peso más 50 centavos es decir el 50
por ciento de un peso entonces lo que yo
estoy esperando que me pagues después de
seis meses
y ojo date cuenta que yo le baje a la
mitad de la tasa de interés lo que yo
estoy esperando que me pagues después de
seis meses es un peso con 50 centavos
150 muy bien esto es después de seis
meses y bueno seguramente tú me dirás
sal esto me agrada mucho más pero bueno
voy a intentar pagarte en seis meses
ahora mi pregunta es qué pasa si de
plano no puedo pagar en seis meses
después de esos seis meses si se cumplen
seis meses con un día te tendré que
pagar los dos pesos de un año yo te voy
a contestar no no no no no no espera
como acabamos de cambiar la tasa de
interés entonces se te va a cobrar un 50
por ciento extra de lo que te voy a
prestar después de seis meses es decir
las cosas van a estar así si yo te lo
presto durante todo un año a una tasa de
interés del 100 por ciento entonces tú
me tendrás que pagar dos pesos en un año
sin embargo si tú aceptas que yo te
cambie la tasa de interés
el 50 por ciento durante los primeros
seis meses si me logras pagar vas a
pagarme un peso con 50 centavos sin
embargo si tú no me logras pagar en los
primeros seis meses entonces te voy a
prestar un peso con 50 centavos otra vez
al 50 por ciento de tasa de interés es
decir si tú necesitas el dinero durante
el año entero entonces como la tasa de
interés cambio me vas a tener que pagar
el 50 por ciento del 150 que me debes es
decir si tú necesitas el dinero en la
segunda parte del año
me deberías de la primera parte del año
unos 50 y de la segunda parte del año el
50% del 150 que me debes vamos a
escribir los 150 que es lo que me debe
ser el primer los primeros seis meses
más el 50% del 150 que son 75 centavos
75 centavos que es el 50 por ciento del
150 que ya me debes esto sé que me vas a
pagar en total después de un año y esto
va a ser igual a unos 50 más punto 75
con 25 centavos como todo en esta vida
tiene sus pros y sus contras el haber
cambiado de tasa de interés si nosotros
logramos pagar este préstamo de los
primeros seis meses vamos a pagar mucho
menos sin embargo si no logras pagar tu
deuda en los primeros seis meses y te
alargas a pagarla hasta el año entonces
vas a pagar más de lo que pagaba en tu
tasa de interés del 100% de hecho a
estar pagando el 125 por ciento de
interés anual esto en el segundo caso en
el caso en el que cambiamos la tasa de
interés al 50% cada seis meses y en ese
momento tú me dices sal estoy en una
situación realmente muy difícil y creo
que voy a optar por la segunda opción
aunque sé que tal vez si no pago en seis
meses voy a terminar pagando más
la segunda opción me parece mejor pero
qué va a pasar sal si yo logro pagarte
este mismo dinero en un lapso de un mes
y yo te voy a decir bueno vamos a
utilizar el mismo concepto si tú me lo
pagas en un mes entonces yo te voy a
cobrar a ver
tenemos que en un año te estoy cobrando
el 100 por ciento en un mes sería el 100
por ciento dividido entre 12 meses es
decir 100 entre 12 que es lo mismo que
50 entre 6 que es lo mismo que 25 entre
3 que es 8.3 te voy a cobrar el 8.5 por
ciento de interés mensual
este es el tercer escenario el primer
escenario era el 100 por ciento anual el
segundo escenario es 50 por ciento cada
seis meses y el tercer escenario va a
ser 8.5 por ciento de interés mensual y
date cuenta como un poco poco tu deuda
no se está construyendo lo que se conoce
como interés compuesto el interés
compuesto se refiere a sacar el interés
de una cantidad que ya tenía un cierto
interés por lo tanto vamos a regresar al
tercer escenario donde yo te iba a
cobrar el 8.5 por ciento de interés
mensual entonces si yo te doy en un
inicio un capital de un peso que va a
pasar o cuánto me vas a pagar después de
un mes bueno lo primero que vas a pagar
es un peso va a ser el peso que yo te
preste más el 8.5 por ciento de ese
es decir más punto 185 lo que me da de
total 1.0 85 pesos esto es en el primer
mes y ojo fue punto 0 85 porque teníamos
una tasa del 8.5 por ciento de interés
mensual ahora bien si nos fijamos en el
segundo mes lo que vamos a tener que
pagar es 1.0 85 elevado a la segunda
potencia podemos hacer las cuentas y
vamos a ver que realmente el resultado
es esto en el tercer mes vamos a pagar
1.085 elevado a la tercer potencia y así
sucesivamente hasta que lleguemos al
doceavo mes en el doceavo mes pagaríamos
1.0 85 elevado a la doceava potencia y
para realizar esta operación voy a sacar
el programa excel y lo voy a calcular
aquí para compararlo con los demás datos
tengo 1.85 elevado en la potencia 12 me
da 2.66 2.66 entonces esto es la doceava
potencia es 2.66 pesos es decir estamos
pagando mucho más que con las otras
tasas de interés si dejamos que nuestra
deuda corre durante lo largo de todo el
año
fíjate que otra forma de decirlo sería
que estamos pagando el 166 por ciento de
nuestra deuda original después de que
transcurrió un año y seguramente tú te
estás preguntando de dónde salió este
1.0 85 elevado al cuadrado para quitarte
esta duda voy a intentar hacerlo con
mucho más cuidado al principio me darías
un peso después de un mes me debías 1.0
85 pesos y después de dos meses me vas a
beber 1.0 85 más el 8.5 por ciento de
1.85 es decir más punto cero 85 que
multiplica a 1.0 85 es justo esto que
tengo escrito arriba de color azul ahora
lo que voy a hacer es factorizar el 1.0
85 que multiplica tanto a uno como
apuntó 0 85 por lo tanto yo obtengo 1.0
85 1.0 85 que multiplica a su vez a uno
más punto cero 85 es decir 1.0 85 y 1.0
85 x 1.085 es 1.0 85 al cuadrado que es
justo la cantidad que teníamos después
de dos meses y de manera análoga para
tres meses
así hasta llegar a 12 meses perfecto
creo que hasta aquí vamos quedando
claros ahora voy a intentar hacer el
caso en que tú me vayas pagando cada día
es decir que nuestro interés correa
durante los 365 días del año entonces
vamos a escribirlo yo lo que quiero es
que tú me pagues cada día entonces esta
vez va a ser un interés por día y
entonces la tasa de interés va a estar
dada por la cantidad 100% dividida entre
365 días que tiene un año por lo tanto
siguiendo la misma lógica que hemos
utilizado en todos los demás casos me
vas a deber 1 punto 1.100 entre 365
cuántos esto voy a sacar otra vez excel
y bueno quiero 100 entre 365 y esto es
igual a
por cien entre 365 no igual asciende
entre 335 que es 0.27 0.27 39 0.27
entonces tengo punto 27 por ciento y si
a esto le agregamos un no voy a tener
1.0 27 elevado todo a la 365 porque lo
que yo quiero es que cada día tú tengas
un cierto interés entonces al total de
un año me vamos a pagar esta cantidad
elevada a la 365 y esta cantidad
desigualdad se nos ha acabado el tiempo
mejor lo vemos en el siguiente vídeo